what's going on guys today we're going
to continue theorizing how attack on
titan would have changed if levi had
chosen irvin to inherit the colossal
titan this video is my favorite what if
scenario i've done so far as it explores
an alternate version of the attack on
mali which includes aaron zeke and
obviously evan himself doing crazy
things that majorly deviate from the
main timeline
for those of you that haven't seen part
one of what if evan got the colossal
that video ended with evan and kyomi
coming to an agreement that would see
both sides and potentially the middle
eastern alliance all working together to
put an end to mali's warriors if you
want to know how or why an alliance with
the middle east might have been possible
then i strongly recommend checking out
part one but today in part two we're
going to begin things with a two-year
time skip from the last video
before we get into it however i'm giving
away a special edition beast titan funko
and a regular size levi to go with it
and all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is simply sub to the
channel and leave a comment below as
long as you are subscribed your comment
will have a chance of being randomly
selected as the winner just like jordan
who won the first giveaway we did in
part one
okay so the best place to start this
video off is in mali where the situation
would be getting incredibly tense
thanks to a completely anonymous source
the military higher-ups would have
received credible evidence that spies
from parodies have infiltrated the
country and are about to launch a
revenge attack on malian soil although
the identity of these alden spies are
unknown it's entirely possible they have
the power of multiple titan shifters
among them including the founder or
maybe even the colossal so if they were
to strike it could be the biggest
disaster marley's had in like the last
100 years
this is why the warrior unit and
commander mcgath have been back home on
the continent for nearly a month having
been temporarily recalled from their war
against the mid-east alliance
a decision to take them away from the
war and recall them back to mali
wouldn't be as controversial as you
might expect considering most of the
mideast war was fought in the sea with
no place for titans to intervene anyway
but still it would give the middle
eastern forces a temporary advantage
in the few weeks since reiner and the
gang have been back on the mainland
parodies surprisingly haven't launched
any attacks and crucially no movement
from alden spies has been detected by
marine intelligence this inactivity
would cause the general to rethink his
strategy and at warrior hq he'd ordered
the beast and draw titan to be
redeployed to the middle east in a few
days while reiner and peak will be
staying behind in mali as a precaution
some time after the meeting is done zeke
would innocently invite his fellow
warriors and their family for dinner the
following evening so they can all have a
meal together prior to him and porker
going back to the war of course the
others would agree to come since they
have no reason to say no and once they
finish talking zeke was strolling to his
office as the others head towards the
internment zone
in his office the captain would lock the
door as he quickly writes down certain
times and locations on a piece of paper
and then places it inside his pocket
alongside something else he'd then make
his way out of hq as discreetly as
humanly possible making sure not to draw
any attention as he walks in the
direction of a nearby alleyway in this
alleyway would be a mystery man who'd
been waiting for the last few hours and
after seeing zeke he start asking
questions about the internment zone and
a few other things to which the beast
titan would simply pass on the letter he
wrote
zeke would also take two vials out of
his pocket that each contain a
transparent liquid before handing them
over to the man and then immediately
making his way back to the gates of
liberio
flashing forward around 24 hours mcgath
would be in the middle of giving a
briefing in preparation for the beast
and draw titan going away he'd explain
that more troops will be brought down
from the mountains to patrol the streets
of mali while random blottis will
continue to be carried out to discover
any aldian spies hiding in the general
population as the meeting goes on rhino
would start doubting whether he has what
it takes to protect his homeland and
zika porko's absence especially given
that he still suffers from nightmares
and ptsd to this day
that being said towards the end of the
briefing he gets some slight reassurance
from mcgath who claimed that a weapon
arrived at hq last night that's capable
of taking down a titan at this time the
commander wouldn't be allowed to go into
further details about what this weapon
is but he'd mention it to reassure peak
and reiner that they'll have backup in
case things take a bad turn
zeke would naturally be the one to press
mcgowan from the details of what this
new weapon is but the commander wouldn't
give anything away as only the very
highest ranked officers would be aware
of its presence in the city
later that evening everyone would arrive
at the warrior captain's house for
dinner with reina bringing his mother
pique bringing her dad and poco bringing
both of his parents interestingly zeke's
own grandparents would be absent from
the meal but he'd probably claim that
they were feeling unwell which i guess
is a believable excuse considering their
age and mental state
hours later all the guests would be
having a good time with the food and
wine being almost completely finished
but throughout the night the beast would
make sure never to lose track of the
time
around 10 o'clock he politely asked his
guest to leave and as the galliard and
bourne families make their way home zeke
would pull peek to the side for a quick
chat
moving over to rhina's house he and
karina would arrive home within 10
minutes or so and the vice captain would
head upstairs to his childhood bedroom
entering the room he'd instantly notice
a breeze coming through the open window
and as he closes it someone would
suddenly shut the door behind him
rider would turn around to see none
other than aaron fricken jaeger in the
corner of his room fully kitted out in
the upgraded odm gear and i imagine his
shock would be even worse than it was in
the main series it's not that he'd be
surprised the owners in mali because the
evidence already implied that might have
been the case but instead ryan's fear
would come from the fact that he's being
confronted in the one place he's most
vulnerable with his mother being
downstairs the armor titan can't even
think about transforming without risking
killing her in the process but by
contrast eren has nothing to lose and
could be ready to blow up the whole
neighborhood at any given time
switching back to zeke and peak these
two would be walking along the streets
of the internment zone having dropped
her father back home zeke's ultimate
goal at this point would be to lure her
into this building and i'm sure he'd
tell her any lie to make that happen you
guys maybe let me know in the comments
what you think he would say to try and
convince her to follow him but
regardless of what he says i think she'd
still be suspicious of the fact that you
know he only wants to bring her and not
rhino and polka as well on top of that
zeke knows firsthand that peek is a
smart girl who could realize if she's
being taken to a trap which is why i
think he'd have a backup plan already in
place
the wine that peek's dad was drinking
from all evening contains the warrior
captain's spine of fluid so if pete
tries to resist him in any way he can
always rely on that backup and threaten
to turn her dad into a pure titan
anyway once they make it to this
building zeke would be the one to
personally cut the robe trapping peak in
this underground container that was
specifically designed to restrain titan
shifters
seconds later a handful of scouts would
enter the room including nile and hanji
and their priority is securing the cart
titan in case any malian soldiers enter
the internment zone dozens more scouts
would be on the surrounding rooftops
ready to provide support while commander
ervin would also be outside for a very
different reason
as zeke exits the building everyone
would maneuver down from the rooftops
and onto the street coming face to face
with the man who essentially killed him
four years earlier
at the brawn household aaron would have
forced reiner to take a seat by now as
the two of them have a massively awkward
conversation aaron would start
aggressively asking loaded questions
about why his mother had to die and if
karina's life is somehow more valuable
than carlos meanwhile rhino would just
be sitting there trying not to say
anything to piss him off
it should be mentioned that this version
of aaron has had different experiences
to the one in the main show with a big
deviation being that he never went rogue
in mali
it was that experience living on the
continent that changed his perspective
in the final season as he realized the
aliens in liberia were just people no
different to the people on paradise
in this new timeline however aaron never
had that realization and as a result his
demeanor would be angrier because he'd
be more motivated by the vengeful spark
inside him that wants to make reiner
suffer as much as possible
from downstairs karina would hear some
of the noise and call out to her son to
ask if he's okay but aaron would signal
for him not to reply this would cause
ryan to break down under the guilt
because he'd understand that it was his
decision to carry on with the mission
that day that has indirectly led to his
friends being dead and now his hometown
being in danger he'd likely collapse at
the ground and beg aaron to kill him as
long as liberia was left unharmed while
simultaneously as this is going on
karina would start making her way up the
stairs
across the street flock mikasa and the
rest of levi's squad would be observing
the situation from the rooftops waiting
for aaron to come back outside the
original plan was for him to hide inside
the property cat trying to buy surprise
and then chop off his limbs and aaron
was sent him by himself because as a
titan shifter he's the only one who
could survive if the armored titan
decided to transform
while that possibility was always
unlikely with his mother being in the
house evans still wouldn't want to take
any chances with this because the scouts
have been burned by rhino one too many
times in the past
as the squad try and get a look through
rana's bedroom window they noticed
karina opening the bedroom door and with
barely any time to process that
information the house would explode in
front of their eyes with the attack
titan emerging from the flames
an incomplete armor titan would be lying
face down in the rubble and leva would
think to himself that he should have
known error might do something like this
on the ground the armored would be
lacking in energy due to his less than
enthusiastic will to live but he
desperately tried to pick himself up to
search for karina before that can happen
though the attack titan would just start
absolutely beating the out of him
as the innocent civilians start running
out of their homes and away from the
battle
i imagine during this one-sided fight
aaron would do something totally
unnecessary like maybe throwing rhino
into an apartment building or doing
something like that because to him this
beatdown is payback for everything the
warriors did to parodies mikasa and jon
would likely be apprehensive about the
excessive loss of innocent life that
eren is causing as captain levi would be
checking his stopwatch to make sure they
have time for this
now in case any of you are wondering
about porco he'd probably just be at
home relaxing totally unaware of what
his comrades are going through unlike
what happened to reiner there wouldn't
have been any scouts waiting for him
inside his own house but there would be
around 20 soldiers monitoring him from
the rooftops i think he'd first start to
realize something's wrong when waves of
civilians start running past his house
and when galileo eventually goes to
check outside he'd see an apartment
building collapse once reiner gets
thrown into it after seeing that he'd
100 get triggered like he always does
and one in the direction of the action
the 20 scouts on the roof would start
training behind him as he gets closer
and closer to erin and they start firing
at porco once he makes it into some open
space away from the civilians in his
human form galliard would manage to
dodge a few of these bullets but at some
point he would get shot in a non-fatal
area
at the same time aaron would continue
beating the stuffing under the armored
titan and in desperation ryan would
scream so loudly that it could be heard
from outside the internment zone four
years earlier in shiganshina he used a
similar tactic to get the attention of
his fellow warriors but this time around
i think he'd also be hoping to get the
attention of commander mcgath and his
alleged titan killing weapon
the armored by himself simply doesn't
have enough strength to fight aaron and
the whole lever squad by himself so
without backup he will die without
knowing whether his mother is alive
under the rubble
a moment after his scream the draw titan
would appear in his neighborhood at high
speed having used his injury from being
shot as the catalyst for his
transformation in this titan form he'd
managed to quickly kill a couple of the
scouts that were training him but the
remaining 18 of them would still be just
behind the members of levi's squad would
obviously see porco trying to charge her
eren and mikasa would be the one to fire
off her thunderspear to send him flying
backwards
meanwhile after getting some
instructions from levi aaron would stop
messing around with reiner and he'd back
away as jean connie and sasha launch a
coordinated thunderspear attack this
attack would completely blow reiner out
of his shell while at the same time the
draw titan would continue to be ripped
apart by the dozens of scouts
surrounding him
rewinding the clock a bit outside the
internment zone commander mcgath would
have been woken up by the sounds of
hundreds of panicking aldians
at hq he'd attempt to call the homes of
each warrior with no response while the
general would start organizing troops to
surround liberio
from their office they each would have
heard the armor titan scream which i
mentioned earlier and this would confirm
to mcgath that one of his shifters has
to be in serious trouble
we've seen in the anime how he doesn't
like the warriors being put in risky
situations where they could lose their
power so even though he doesn't know
what's happened to reiner he'd realize
that he needs to send in some support
just in case
not that long afterwards hundreds of
malian troops would be making their way
to the walls under the general's orders
but these preparations would be
interrupted by a strange object flying
out of the internment zone a single
wooden barrel would race over their
heads as it flies further into the city
and as it begins to come down a quick
flash of lightning would appear followed
by a powerful explosion the blast itself
would instantly flatten a lot of marlin
infrastructure including the train
station buildings roads parts of the
wall and like 90 of warrior hq
towards the center of the internment
zone even the scouts would be feeling
some intense blowback but evan
intentionally wouldn't have done a
maximum blast so he could minimize that
risk
thanks to information they acquired from
zeke the main purpose of this
transformation would be to wipe out the
high-ranking marlin offices at hq
thereby destabilizing the chain of
command
as we know most other high-ranking
officers would be in the middle east
right now dealing with that war so the
blow from irvine means that the troops
in liberia no longer have any leaders to
coordinate them that by itself gives
parodies and his roo a perfect window to
launch the next stage of their invasion
but first they need to take the
remaining shifters out of malian hands
switching back into the internment zone
aaron would pick up the draw titan's
decimated body and prepare to bite the
nape but he paused when the beast titan
appears from around the corner
as zeke walks in their direction
galliard would be the most excited
person to see him but he'd realized
pretty quickly that something was wrong
contrary to what poker would expect the
beast titan wouldn't try to save him or
even attack the survey core in fact i
imagine he'd just be casually strolling
through the street
eventually zeke would crouch down to
examine reiner's tied up unconscious
body and as he picks it up nearly all
the scouts would make their way onto the
rooftops to watch
the only remaining soldier on ground
level would be flock and everyone else
would be observing from above as he
walks closer to the beast titan
zeke would likely ask him if he's sure
about what's about to happen and the
scout would have to give him some kind
of signal to let him know that he's okay
without hesitation the beast titan would
then scream at the top of his lungs
causing a flashing light to appear where
flock was standing not to mention a few
other lights would simultaneously appear
across the zone
as a side note the whole time this is
going on aaron would still be holding
the draw titan in his hands basically
forcing gallagher to watch this top 10
anime betrayal
when the smoke finally disappears
flock's pure titan would be revealed and
thanks to the way it was created zeke's
full of blood gives him full control
over its actions
the first thing the beast would do would
be to order flock to eat the armored
titan because like i said rhino's
unclear's body would be in the palm of
zeke's hand the flock pier titan would
instantly run towards it as galiad
watches in disbelief but as is usually
the case with reiner i figured he'd get
some kind of plot armor that would save
him just in time as the flock titan is
about to you know reach him and eat him
alive it would get absolutely skewered
by a pillar of hardening that randomly
spirals out the ground behind zeke we
see a fully formed lara type of
warhammer titan approaching and in case
you didn't guess the warhammer would be
the titan killing weapon that mcgath was
referring to earlier because at this
stage in the timeline the only weapon
that marley has that can destroy titan
shifters is shifters of their own
anyway with that said that is the end of
part two of what if everyone got the
colossal titan and if you liked it then
be sure to drop a like and subscribe so
you don't miss future videos like this
when i began making part two i didn't
originally plan to do a time skip but
you know i realized in the end that it
would be more interesting to skip ahead
to the battle in liberio but as we
continue it will become more obvious
what happened in those two years before
i go don't forget to comment if you want
to enter the prize draw for the beast
titan plus levi giveaway and full
details are in the description for how
the contest works thanks for watching as
always and until the next one peace out